now what did Andrew Tate just do would
you also the man himself here what
canceled the legend is here in Charlotte
his new home and let's get into this
video and then I'll come back and I'll
break it down for you I'm going to bring
you a very special show soon to all the
people who supported him his hallway bro
thank you very much man thank you glad
to be here
Russian
foreign
the future of our great country the
future of mankind this is your brother
and I've got a very important message
alhamdulillah our brother Eddie is
setting up the dean Center not just the
dean show but the dean Center a full
dawa Academy a Masjid a dawa Center in
America the first of its type the a
groundbreaking project and I want
everybody as I'm supporting it I want
everybody to support it so we can take
the dawah to the next level we need the
dean Center please support it foreign
[Music]
now here are a few things that I want to
share with you if Andrew take did accept
Islam right off the bat he would have
went to the most important thing he went
from throwing up the Trinity to throwing
up the pure monotheism which is called
taheed
which for any thinking person rational
person knows that this is rational
logical and this is something that all
the prophets of God like Abraham Moses
Jesus and last final mission to mankind
Muhammad did and he went from worshiping
the creation to worshiping the crater if
Andrew take did accept Islam all you see
him doing right there is mimicking the
way that Jesus prayed isn't that
something amazing if Andrew Tate truly
did accept Islam and we prayed to God
Almighty Allah that he did and inshallah
if not now soon that he is following his
fitra brothers and sisters and all of
humanity out there what's the fitra
that's the innate disposition of the
human being to want to worship and
submit to the creator of all not to the
creation that way of life of submitting
your will not to yourself to your
desires not to a human being to Angels
Saints Messengers no but to the one
crater up above the creator of the
heavens and earth God Almighty Allah and
this is Islam to submit your will
entirely to the creator of the heavens
and earth just like in the Lord's Prayer
or our father or in heaven Hallowed be
thy name thy kingdom come thy will be
done that is Islam to submit your will
to the will of the Creator God Almighty
Allah that's what Andrew take did if he
did accept Islam and one final thing I
want to share with you if he did accept
Islam he's our brother and the Deen he's
our brother in Islam so everything that
he has done in the past you can't hold
that over him of course you get the
chance to advise him if you meet him
lovingly kindly to go ahead and leave
because it's just transition it takes
time but anything a human being would
have done in the past it doesn't matter
all those things get wiped out that's
the beauty of Islam that a person can
have sins up to the heavens and earth
but if he calls on God Almighty alone
and he asks God Almighty to forgive this
individual male or female and he truly
submits his or her will and he comes
into this beautiful way of life of Islam
submission to the Creator not the
creation and he agrees what's in his
very nature following the fifth like we
talked about his innate disposition
following the way of Jesus Moses Abraham
the last the final messenger sent to
mankind he says
meaning I testify I bear witness I swear
that there's nothing worthy of worship
not the cars not the money nothing not
Jesus not the son not the moon nothing
that you can fathom or imagine in
creation is worthy of worship now tell
me that doesn't make sense accept the
creator of the heavens and the Earth the
one who created Jesus the one who
created Moses the one that Jesus called
people to worship because Jesus never
ever claimed that he was God a literal
Son of God and calling people to worship
Him never so this is the testimony that
he would take to bring him into the full
of Islam and that Muhammad is the last
messenger said to mankind easy
straightforward all the previous sins
are forgiven so you can't hold those
things up against his head whatever he
has done in the past but he can go ahead
and rectify his Affairs and start to
call people away from debauchery from a
life of gambling from a life of alcohol
promiscuity he can promote Family Values
he can promote all these good things
because he'd be truly a man of God a man
who loves his creator and he loves what
his creator loves and he hates what his
creator hates so slowly but surely he
would be away from all these things the
more he did Islam the more you live
Islam you know Islam you know your
creator you love your creator you feel
your creator you live between fear
you're in Hope and you live for the next
life of Jannah of paradise and you fear
the Hellfire so you want to be an
upright outstanding human being and
that's what Islam motivates you teaches
you to be so that's in a nutshell what
Andrew Tate by taking that first step he
would
be doing believing and God willing
inshallah Andrew Tate inshallah connect
with you again my brother and I pray for
you that God Almighty Allah guides you
and I leave you with the simple homework
now that you have got to experience what
it is to pray like Jesus like Moses like
Abraham like Prophet Muhammad peace and
blessings be upon Him continue to do
that if you haven't already accepted
Islam and ask the creator of the heavens
and earth keep asking beseeching
earnestly Guide Me Guide Me Guide Me
while your head is in the lowest
position that it can be and like I said
this is the way that Jesus prayed so
you're only mimicking him because he
only prayed to the Creator he didn't
pray to himself nor was he God called
upon himself he was calling upon God
Almighty Allah and Aramaic same thing
Allah enough said I hope that this has
helped you understand the situation a
little bit better and we'll see you next
time peace be with you thought on uh
Islam and everything because I know in
the in the Quran and stuff like you
could have up to four wives and stuff so
I've seen you talk about it a little bit
but I would like to know like what you
think about it
I think it's the last religion on the
planet
that's the right religion I think it's
the last religion so if it's if it's the
last True Religion on the planet then it
has to be the correct one cannot leave
without giving you a gift if you're not
yet Muslim and you're tuning in to see
what these Muslims are talking about and
you like a free copy of the Quran go and
visit thedineshow.com we'll take care of
the postage and everything and get it
delivered to you and if you still have
some questions
about Islam call us at
1-800-662-4752 we'll see you next time
until then peace be with you and if you
like this episode of the dean show like
this video
share this video far and wide and
support us on our patreon page so we can
continue this work thank you for tuning
in peace be with you assalamualaikum